17 Honda Civic we got a new key for you
bud got the autofix B1 Pro right
here connect to the vehicle ignition on
engine off and go into control unit
keyless access control unit so from here
we'll go into
registration keyless access
remote add a keyless access remote
blah blah blah blah blah hit
okay no dccs blah blah blah hit
[Applause]
okay ignition off please take one
original keyless access remote into the
vehicle remove all other keys so I have
the new key outside of the window hit
okay ignition on
[Music]
now we take all original keyless access
remotes out of the vehicle so we'll take
the original key out of the vehicle hit
okay new key in the vehicle hit
[Music]
okay and there we go finition
off so I still got the new one outside
of the
car ignition on ignition is turning on
so I know she's
programmed give her SEC make sure the
immobile light's turned off it sure
is complete ignition
off back on again for some
reason all right that's it esape es
scape es
scape scap
and
esape all right let's make sure it
starts the car there we go beautiful